It was sent to William and he sent it to
me. So I said, "Let me deal with it.
Where is it, man?" So there's several
clips. He had a debate with Cliff and
his son. So I'm going to address the one
clip.
I didn't know they had a debate with
Cliff and his son. And in this clip,
he's claiming victory for embarrassing
Cliff. Lord willing, I'll go through all
the clips and I'll start a playlist on
all the discussions I had with black
Hebrews rights and where they were
refuted. So, are you ready? Now, we're
going to go into it. Pray for me to
destroy the blasphemous lies and
practice what I preach and I die. Wash
in the blood of Jesus Christ. Learn
these arguments, master these arguments,
make them your own. So, let's go into
it. So, I don't know where you can find
a full discussion,
but he has clips. Let's start with this
clip.
This is the one I'm going to respond to
now. Warning.
There is an Fbomb that you're going to
hear. So, warning.
>> Who really was God who humbled himself
and became a human being? He's the
eternal God.
>> Does Christ have a God?
>> No, he's the eternal God.
>> In John 21 and 25, Christ said, "I go to
my father and your father, my God and
your God." Christ said he has a God out
of his own mouth. So, how can he be God
if he got a God?
>> Got him. We [__] got him.
>> See,
>> that's right.
>> About Christ who really was God who
humbled himself and became a human
being. He's the eternal God.
>> Does Christ have a God?
>> No. He Jared Cliff said no. And of all
the podcasts he can appear on, he
appeared with this guy who's known to
mock people, ridicule people, insult
people because it's pretty much he's a
clown that clowns people. I'm not
putting him down, but that's what he's
known for. This guy here,
why would you go on this of all
platforms where this guy, look at him,
see his partner pretending to be asleep.
Does Christ have a God? He said, "No,
Cliff and his son." And this is going to
be a teaching moment. Number one, it's
not John 21:25. He made a mistake. John
21:25 is not the past. John 20:17. But
we're going to have fun. I've already
addressed this objection millions of
times. I have articles on it.
Nonetheless, it's making the rounds.
Why would Cliff and his son agree to
debate? This is going to confirm
something I've said, and I'm going to
use this as a teaching moment. Now,
there are other clips I'll watch to see
what else he schooled Cliff on, and I'll
respond to it, God willing, in the
upcoming weeks.
So, there you go. But now, this confirms
what I've said. You must stay in your
own lane.
Cliff and his son are evangelists.
They are not apologists. They are not
theologians. They're not scholars.
Cliff
and his son are evangelists.
They are not apologists. They're not
theologians. They're not scholars.
They don't know scriptures in depth.
They do not know church history.
It's one thing when you have an
Ethiopian Orthodox deacon schooling him
and an Eastern Orthodox schooling him on
church history because at least
Ethiopian Orthodox, Eastern Orthodox,
they go back to the apostles. Their
churches are ancient
goes back to the apostles. They have
sound trinitarian theology, sound
christologology,
right? because they do affirm Christ as
truly God, truly human, one uncreated
person. It's just the way those natures
are united in the person, they will
differ and use different language, but
it's same Christologology at the end of
the day, right? So they're ancient. So
when he gets schooled by them, glory to
God. Why? Because then people will then
go back to the ancient roots, ancient
past, ancient traditions of the church.
Whereas when you have a black Hebrew
Israelite who thinks Jesus is a man
because not all black Hebrew Israelites
believe the same thing. They're not
monolithic. You'll get a variety of
flavors of black Hebrew Israelites.
Tazarak believes Jesus is just the man.
No more. No less.
No more. No less. So when you allow
someone who thinks the white man is the
devil and the white man will be his
slave and the Israel Israelites are
these races right from Africa and other
places and think Jesus is just a man no
more no less I don't know what he thinks
about the Holy Spirit that is pitiful
and disgraceful and shameful
let's get into the topic it wasn't John
21:25 to Zaria It was John 2017. This is
one of the first objections I answered
when I began full-time ministry 1999. I
started doing fulltime ministry by
writing for
yeah Captain Crunch Answering Islam that
started 1998.
I became the main writer. Thank the Lord
Jesus for stirring your hearts and thank
you for responding because without that
support I wouldn't be able to do it. In
spite of my sins and failures, the Lord
Jesus pies me, forgives me, washes me,
and restores me. Thank you, Lord. Never
let me go. Now, let's get into the
answer.
How can Jesus be God if he has a God?
Let's answer it. I won't go to my
article. I just go to the Bible.
Now, notice he said John 21:25. It's not
John 21:25. It's John 20:17.
But
I'm going to show you that the
scriptures teach it's not either or,
it's both. And because he thinks Christ
is just a man, just human.
He thinks then if he has a God, then he
can't be God. John 17, Jesus said to
her, "Stop clinging to me, for I've yet
have for I have not yet ascended to the
father. But go to my brothers and say to
them, I ascend to my father and your
father and my God your God. This is it.
Now, how can you have a god? Very easy.
Ready? Let's unpack the meat.
This is
why he has a god. You ready? Listen,
guys, don't distract. Jeremiah 32:26-27.
You guys know it, but let's go over it
again. Jeremiah 32:26-27.
Then the word of Yahweh came to Jeremiah
saying, Yahweh, ironically, this is
Jesus the word speaking to Jeremiah, but
nonetheless, behold, I am Yahweh, the
God of all flesh. Is anything too
difficult for me?
I am Yahwh, Yahweh, the God of all
flesh. Rumble. See it
right?
Okay. Why is that important? Well, let's
go.
John 1 tells us Jesus
is the word who has been there from the
beginning before even creation came into
being. Now watch. In the beginning was
the word. The word was with God and the
word was God. He was in the beginning
with God. And this word is the one that
the God he's with appointed
to create
all creation and to give life to all
creation. So the God he's with appointed
the word to create all things, preserve
all things, give life to all things, and
illuminate all creation.
Let's unpack this.
part of Christmas, right? Where all
things came into being through him and
apart from nothing came into being that
has come into being. There's not a
single thing that came into existence
that the son is not the cause of.
Heavens and earth were brought into
being by the father through the son and
the spirit, the triune God. And I can
give you receipts for that. But right
now, John is focusing on the word.
Everything that comes comes into being
subsequent from that point, the Lord
Jesus is personally involved in bringing
that into being. So when your mothers
get pregnant, that's the Lord allowing
the seed to fertilize the oam, creating
a life, and he is the one who's
fashioning that life
and bringing a newborn baby into
existence. And he does that not just for
humans, animals, marine life. He's
sustaining all of it.
That's what it's saying.
Nothing would exist and come into being
without his agency.
In him was life. Meaning the life that
preserves all creation, that sustains
all creation
originates from him. He is the source of
that life.
And that life also gives you
illumination to find yourself out of
darkness into the light of salvation. So
he is the light that illuminates men.
Okay, you see who the word is. Okay, now
follow me. Let's unpack this because how
does it tie in
to Christ having a god? Because you go
on here, there was the true light which
coming into the world enlightens
everyone. Now what John is saying is the
Lord Jesus as the word before he became
flesh from the only virgin has been
illuminating everyone from the
beginning. He didn't start illuminating
them when he came into the world. He's
been the illumination
the light that has been shining in all
mankind giving them rays of truth. So
let me ask you a question.
If Yahweh is the God of all flesh
and then the word of God who's not the
father but he is the son who is God the
one who creates all things sustains all
things illuminate all things he becomes
flesh coming forth from the father to do
the father's will.
If he became flesh and the father did
not and he became flesh to do the
father's will. John 6:38, "I've come
down from heaven not to do my will, but
the will of him who sent me." Why would
it shock you that because he's flesh,
the father became his God?
You got it.
trustes with Jesus Christ. He's now
whole and deathless.
So if the word became flesh to do the
father's will, the father not become
flesh.
Would the father simply be his father or
would he also be his god because he's
also man,
right?
And I'm going to prove to you prior to
him becoming flesh, Jesus did not have a
god.
Though he existed before he was flesh,
he didn't have a god before he was
flesh. Now, why does he still have a
god? Because this is after the
resurrection, right?
It's after the resurrection. Well, let's
see.
Jesus has been raised from the dead.
It's that first Easter Sunday. Mary
Magdalene sees him, clings to his feet,
weeping.
Jesus said to her, "Stop clinging to me,
for I've not yet ascended to the Father.
But go to my brothers, say to them, I
ascend to my father and your father. My
God, your God." So why is it that after
the resurrection,
Jesus still has
God
over him? That he still has the father
acting as God over him. Well, the answer
is here, guys. Let me show you right
here. The Bible has all the answers
here. Let me show you. Watch. You ready?
Let's same chapter, right? Number one.
So why does Jesus still have a god over
him?
Why does Jesus still have a god over
him? Note the same chapter. If you
forgive the sins of any, their sins have
been forgiven them. If you retain the
sins of any, they have been retained.
But Thomas, one of the 12 called Ditimus
was not with them when Jesus came. So
the other disciples were saying to him,
"We have seen the Lord." But when he
said to them, "Unless I see in his hands
the imprint of the nails, and put my
finger into the place of the nails, put
my hand into his side, I will not
believe." Now notice, Thomas was told,
"The Lord is alive. He's been
resurrected." Like he said,
we've seen him. Now he says, "Well, hold
on. If he has been resurrected, that
means that physical body, listen to
this, that physical body
that was buried has come to life. He has
entered his body. He's rean reanimated
that body. So if it's that same body,
because there is no resurrection, that's
not bodily. The Jews had no concept of a
resurrection that wasn't a physical
bodily resurrection. So if you're
telling me he's been raised, that means
he reanimated that physical body. He's
in that body again. That means that body
will still have the holes of the nails
in his hands and the hole
in his side from the piercing of the
spear.
Which means that Christ is still
fleshly.
Christ is still fleshly. Pray for this
young man. Lord have mercy on you,
brother. Jesus loves you. Don't be
afraid. He's with you, brother. All
right. Jesus still has a physical body
and it's fleshly. And he still has the
holes in his hands inside as an
everlasting reminder to us. This is the
price I paid for you.
I love you so much that I chose to die
to have you than live without you. But
knowing that if I were to redeem you,
not only would I become flesh and be
beaten to a bloody pulp, nailed and
buried, I would then reanimate that body
and unite myself to that body with the
holes forever and never discarded. And
that's the price I chose to pay because
that's how much I love you. This is the
story of Christmas.
Which means he knew that he'd have to
remain in the flesh, remain a man
forever. Something that was not true
before Christmas. And he knew all this
and he did it anyway where he willfully
subjected himself to human nature, a
physical body, a physical body. And
human nature he will never discard. So
never sees being a man, never sees
having a physical body of flesh that's
immortal, deathless, and never sees
being in the flesh, and never stop
having a god over him.